baloran's Team Deathmatch is awesome
it's become one of the best ways to warm
up before hopping into rank then it's
genuinely changed the game but is that
actually a good thing well it's kind of
complicated
last month I was invited to test out
valorent's new game mode and I'm always
excited to try out new content but when
I heard that it was Team Deathmatch I
honestly thought to myself who asked was
it you did you ask let me know in the
comments because I genuinely don't know
like seriously who the asked for
Team Deathmatch nobody even likes normal
death match and we already have game
modes like Spike rush and Swift play
where we can run around and have fun so
I went into the play test with pretty
low expectations but then something
weird happened I kind of had fun I got
on by pros and content creators but
I had fun I was worried when I saw that
you could use abilities but I think that
Riot did a really good job implementing
them while maintaining a focus on
Gunplay the four stages allow you to use
different tiers of weapons ranging from
pistols to SMGs and then rifles so you
can choose your own personal Loadout for
each stage you're on a 10 minute timer
and it's first to 100 kills but games
typically only take five to seven
minutes and you have way more
opportunities to actually shoot your gun
compared to standard death it's a great
game mode if you don't have time to
commit to a full match and maybe you
just want to turn your brain off and
mess around for a bit and so far
everyone loves it I think you just get
it
can't see James
my clip no can't see
[Music]
honest it's like I'm death matching but
an actual death match
thank you come on come on come on yeah
shut down
TDM's amazing I think that uh by far is
my favorite game mode in the game
including ranked uh I think it's just
just
fun you know uh you don't care about
baiting teammates you don't care about
no-com teammates you just get to chew
your gun and not to worry about like I
don't know just being mad at like people
sound whoring or like
what not it's it's I don't know it's
just a lot more laid back I think that
Wright did a great job at actually
designing maps that were made for that
game mode uh whereas in Death Match you
just play free fall Deathmatch on the uh
maps that were designed for the standard
uh Spike defusal game mode considering
that you know they kind of actually
designed it so that TDM could be fun and
that it wouldn't be a lot of running
around and looking for people uh which
is kind of where you know CS go missed
their mark on TDM EDM is yeah very very
fun TDM is basically just constant
gunfights which is great if you're
trying to get warmed up I've already
heard a lot of people say that it's
replaced normal Deathmatch in that
regard but I still think that it's a bit
of a Band-Aid fix valorent is seriously
lacking proper practice tools the range
is okay but you're pretty limited to
what you can do and it doesn't come
anywhere close to what you see from
something like aimbots and CS go and
worst of all we still can't use the
range while we're in queue and that
drives me nuts it means that a lot of us
have to turn to aim trainer like Kovacs
and aim lab which I do think are great
programs but I feel like Riot could come
and fill that void if they really wanted
to I shouldn't have to open up an
entirely different program just to stay
warm while I wait in queue being able to
create our own practice scenarios would
be incredible but the big thing that I
want are pre-fire Maps they're great for
practicing General Crosshair placement
and they've helped me improve at CS
aimlab does have this already but a lot
of it is locked behind their 10 monthly
subscription and there's no way I'm
paying that especially when the movement
feels slightly off I could spend that
money on coffee or skins or something so
I hope Riot is at least considering
adding more options to the range but
considering it's been three years since
the game came out I'm not exactly
getting my hopes up it took them over
seven years to implement the practice
tool in League after the game was
released and when they did the community
really enjoyed it it became a valuable
tool for the entire scene from Pros
practicing combos to content creators
comparing builds or even the average
player getting a feel for a champion for
his long as they like it's become part
of the furniture for League fans but who
knows how long it will take to improve
the range in valorant it's been three
years now and we haven't really seen
many changes it's something that I'd
really like to see and I know I'm not
the only one me personally I would like
to see more tools I'd like to see more
options in the range I think that you
know the normal practice mode the boss
are clumped up together to be able to
actually get any meaningful aiming or
micro adjustments or any sort of like
flicking or anything like that uh the
tracking on the strafe Bots is just like
the straight Bots are too sporadic it
doesn't really make sense and I don't
feel like it's realistic like sometimes
they just stay still for like 10 seconds
and that's a waste of my time whereas
like you look at like aimbots on CS go
and you can have like full
customizability you can change how far
they go you can change how many sides
are open you can change like the
patterns of their shapes as well which I
thought was really really cool too that
I used to uh mess around with a lot I
know that Riot is constantly looking for
ways to improve the experience for
casual players and even bring in new
players and I'm sure that TDM will do
that if it hasn't already Counter-Strike
in League of Legends already have game
modes that some players choose to play
almost exclusively so perhaps Riot is
just discovering ways to attract players
who aren't typically interested in the
tax shooter genre game modes like Swift
play and Team Deathmatch are crucial if
valrant is going to continue to grow and
I Gotta Give Riot credit because both
modes were extremely well received when
they came out it may not be the perfect
way to warm up and I still hope we get
more practice tools in the future but
for now I think that Riot killed it with
TDM and my stack will continue to start
every session with it
100 thieves merch that that's what I
said about it I was like it's something
I can like actually like wear outside
and like not be embarrassed to wear like
it it doesn't look like like Esports
merge like there's some stuff you look
at like even this like it's like Esports
merch yeah I want to like support the
guard but like I'm not gonna wear this
outside